I know you were a comedy aficionado who  did you like growing up I well I really  loved Robin Williams for a long time  very very sincerely I loved him I  thought you know when he was doing all  the off-the-wall stuff and then I  started became fascinated with his his  very serious side you know his always  talking about the gift of laughter chief  things oh no it's the gift of laughter  is you know that's why I do it Conan you  know I I want to go to Darfur with you  know just give them the gift of laughter  you know you know you can't help but get  a little bit oh but but you have to  bring it down he can't help himself he  gets a little crazy no because you know  it's like you know nothing quells a  starving African child's belly like a  like a lot of a lot of jokes coordinator  just want to go huh  right now Gandhi somewhere going oh my  god if only I had known but I walk down  boy okay  [Applause]